think I say let's start with the
allegations have you raped anybody
absolutely not have you trafficked
anybody absolutely not exploited any
women for money absolutely not but you
have admitted using emotional
manipulation to get women to work in the
webcam industry for you no media goes
into things they go in with a narrative
and that's why I got so much criticism
for interviewing Nick right I I got so
much criticism for not pushing back for
going in with an open mind but this is
like the level of Journalism that we
have nowadays it's not people looking
for the truth it's people that are
looking to spin a narrative and they
they're not look like does this look
like an open-minded woman looking for
the
facts